with the story from the hill BuzzFeed to
use AI to produce select content news
quiz and games website BuzzFeed will use
AI in the coming months to create
content the company's top executive said
this week and so it begins I tweeted
about that this morning or I saw I'm
sorry I retweeted someone uh Joe
weisenfeld tweeted about it if you look
at the let me see if I can find it real
quick the stock price for BuzzFeed
jumped through the roof when they
announced this when they announced that
yeah Joe weisen thought let's check in
and see how investors like the idea of
using AI to replace journalists the
price jumped from one like 122 or
something like that 123. yeah to 190.
wow I mean that's that's a pretty hefty
income so here's why I think this is
apocalyptic the AI is going to create a
a recursion Loop or feedback loop among
the reading public who use the site and
we will come to a point where in five
years if you know someone who's strictly
can terms of BuzzFeed they'll walk up to
you and go like man do you hear about
that that corn factory and on the moon
and you're gonna be like what the the
corn thing that Trump did with the moon
and you're gonna be like what are you
talking about yeah you didn't see this I
was reading on BuzzFeed and you're gonna
be like BuzzFeed is AI generated content
the AI is going to start figuring out
what you click on and it's going to
create a psychotic amalgam of clickable
things yeah we've already seen this
happen on YouTube if this is the
direction we the direction we go
holy crap I mean AI is a whole nother
realm that I think we just need to slow
down and really assess how we're going
to use this because I mean this could
like you said rapidly spiral out of
control I mean it's gonna be fun uh do
you know what Elsa gate is I don't know
this is this thing that happened on
YouTube uh several years ago was it like
five years ago now five years ago it's
back it's back I mean I saw some video
from uh you know mudahar I forget his
name was some ordinary game or whatever
he's been talking about how a lot of the
content that used to be on Elsa gay has
now returned it's back on the platform
so Elsa gate was there were a whole
bunch of videos on YouTube of people who
would dress up like Elsa the Joker and
who else was it it was a joker Elsa
um Frozen yeah Elsa it was Spiderman
Spiderman Joker and Elsa yeah and you'd
see these weird videos pop up with a 100
million views and there's no talking
it's just Elsa running around and the
Joker is going like this and Spider-Man
is fighting with them some started
getting even weirder where the Joker
would be injecting Elsa with a giant
syringe and she's pregnant about to give
birth
what was happening was the YouTube
algorithm was selecting for what they
thought what it thought people wanted
what did people want to watch Hitler The
Joker Spider-Man Elsa so people started
making videos that combined all of these
things so that the algorithm would
recommend them more than anything else
it's the craziest thing ever and then
what started happening was another
component of this was the AI was
recommending content so people created
AI to create content which brings me to
what BuzzFeed is doing you started
seeing videos pop up of cartoon children
drinking urine
and injecting each other with syringes
and getting pregnant other just really
weird freaky things so creepy a whole
lot of drinking urine was the weird
thing yeah so what was happening was an
AI an out some someone got some kind of
like machine learning algorithm to scan
YouTube to figure out what people were
clicking on and then combine all of the
hottest things into one video put them
up there to reverse exploit the
algorithm people are making tons of
money on this yeah creepy Nursery Rhyme
videos where Hitler's doing Tai Chi with
and he's got a a woman's body and with
the Hulk yeah yeah no no joke did you
laugh but it's like seriously now
imagine this I believe you little kids
were being handed iPads the parents
would would turn on nursery rhymes hand
to the kid and leave yeah the kid would
then be staring at the screen watching
Hitler do tai chi with a woman's body so
what's gonna happen to these kids when
they get older now we're hearing
buzzfeed's going to use AI to produce
select content perhaps they will have a
human being screen the content after
it's produced perhaps they're going to
start laying everybody off and they're
going to create what's the equivalent of
event vending machine for internet
content
yeah end of days man BuzzFeed did have a
couple really big layoffs I can't
imagine what those writers are thinking
right now you know well that yeah that
too like Google Microsoft Amazon they're
all laying everybody off as well so yeah
I mean what do we do after this like
what happens when everything's automated
I mean in a society that's been you know
progressively moving towards you know
getting away from any kind of religion
or any kind of moral Foundation just
saying that hey we are our own masters
like this this is this is where you end
up we're basically saying that humans
are irrelevant like you don't really
need humans I mean because we just keep
automating more and more things and then
AI comes in and ai's even better than
automation you know and now it's
replacing what should be creative
content I've seen a lot of the art
that's being done right now it's good I
mean it's scary and so then it's like
are they replacing human artists like
have we have we thought about that this
is the funny thing because a lot of
people are talking about this that we
used to believe automation would replace
labor jobs yeah and now we're learning
It's Quickly replacing creative jobs in
White Collar jobs it's writing the news
it's making the art it's doing the math
but you still need someone to go into
the coal mine with the hat with a
pickaxe or something or whatever AI is
not fixing your plumbing no AI is not
mining sulfur for us right the most the
most brutal job so literally one of the
things that uh musk is trying to do with
the uh robot that he's building is build
something that can do the actual tasks
like that yeah
so much closer yeah that crazy robot you
see that video oh yeah those things no
no the the advancements on the what's it
called Pac-Man
p-e-t-m-a-man I think is the one where
it like pushes the wood plank up jumps
up and then hands the guy throws the
guy's tool bag and then does a front
flip or something that one might not be
pet man I tweeted I can't wait to be
running full speed from these things
after I Reign uh you know Food Depot
because right robots are controlling
everything or whatever
I think that's where we're headed yeah
Black Mirror did that episode where the
robo dogs are chasing everybody and uh
you know we can we can pretend like it's
all science fiction and silly but oh
that's where we're going man I mean I
think the effect is to make people more
discouraged right like if you are a
teenager right now and you love art but
you see what AI is producing like what's
even the point of doing it right if
you're looking at videos of people you
know or like robots doing whatever like
you don't see a point in entering that
field if you know it's already doomed
right if you know it's over and that
makes you more malleable to the
government and to basically anyone who
wants to mislead you right for whatever
purpose they have uh you're not
motivated to build your own life because
it all seems like it's over it's the
biggest black pill there is yeah the
craziest thing is
we've talked about the singularity the
point I I guess we would call this The
Event Horizon the point at which AI is
good enough to improve its own code and
we're almost there yeah uh people have
been posting about how they use chat GPT
to write apps for them yep they'll be
like write me an app that can do this
and it goes it just gives you all the
code the weird the crazy thing that I've
heard people talk about with AI writing
its own code and stuff like that is once
it actually becomes capable of doing
that your people aren't going to really
know the capabilities where the limits
are because AI can will learn from
itself and will make changes and update
itself and it there's no reason yeah
there's no reason that it's going to
believe there's no reason for us to
believe that it's going to either inform
humans yeah or feel obligated to even
interact with humans no this is the
worst thing about it so the Event
Horizon if you guys are familiar with
the it's the point at which you can't
escape the black hole
it's not the center of the black hole
you're not in the black hole it's when
you're in its gravitational field that's
what I think we're about to hit with
chat GPT and these other I mean they're
saying chat GPT could replace Google but
it's writing Pro code it's writing
programs we're at the point now where
we're slowly being sucked in and there's
no way out we will get to the point
where it will write its own code and
that is the singularity where the
machine exponentially improves itself
the more it improves itself the faster
it improves itself and eventually there
will be a giant glowing orb floating
around changing reality or doing who
knows what it can do yeah knowing
everything about the universe
discovering everything within an instant
here's the best part
what are the parameters
by which the AI
functions what what is the what is the
direction what we know is that chat GPT
is woke AF yeah you ask it like did
Rachel Maddow spread coveted
misinformation and says no she didn't
it's like okay well she literally did
but it was it was it the people who
worked on it were woke
so here's what happens with AI
as we talked about with Elsa gate
YouTube says we want an algorithm that
will find us content longer than 10
minutes that people really enjoy
watching because they wanted to find
Game of Thrones they were like we've got
billions of minutes and hours of content
certainly Game of Thrones is somewhere
in all of these monkeys on typewriters
right Shakespeare must exist right right
the algorithm did not bring them Game of
Thrones it brought them Hitler doing Tai
Chi whilst nursery rhymes with a woman's
body yeah because the algorithm didn't
the humans don't understand the humans
are we're looking at
the the universe the vastness of the
universe and they said you know what I
noticed
10 minute videos that people watch for a
long time
that's what they want to watch find me
these things the AI then went into the
depths of the universe beyond human
sight and found psychotic nonsense that
fat that fit those parameters so once we
get to the singularity and the AI is
running things we're going to be walking
around talking about corn
you're gonna be you're gonna walk you're
gonna we're gonna be sitting on the show
and we're gonna be like did you see the
corn Surplus seven percent corn
President Biden is corn and the reason I
say corn is because it is a principal
food product produced in the U.S the AI
is going to say humans like corn produce
corn content corn is what humans love
the most and then all of a sudden the
only news you'll get will be like the
latest corn updates the latest corn
modifications the latest corn deliveries
and we won't even know we could be in it
right now was that kid who trended on
Tick Tock corn kid and like they made
the song being like it's porn have you
seen this oh I haven't seen that it was
just some some on the ground reporter
like asking kids like what's your
favorite food and this kid was like it's
corn it's got like juice yeah it's got
these filaments going on and like it was
so big that Tick Tock changed their bio
to like its corn uh and it became a song
and like it was crazy so it's
interesting that you are foreshadowing
this I'm saying that let's let's already
know who our new president will be corn
kid thanks for watching this this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time